دكتور وانت تتابع ما يجري في مستشفى ناصر
وكذلك المناطق المحيطه ما هي
اوضاع المستشفى والمنطقه بفعل اطلاق النار
والقصف على
النازحين نعم بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
الوضع في داخل مجمع ناصر الطبي معقد
وكارثي للغايه لا يوجد امكانيه لوصول
سيارات الاسعاف او الخروج منها لمجمع ناصر
طبي وكذلك ايضا مستشفى الهلال مستشفى
الامل التابع للهلال الاحمر الفلسطيني
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي يقوم باستهداف مركز
لمحيط مستشفى ناصر بخان يونس هذا
الاستهداف يؤدي الى انتشار الشبايه داخل
ساحات المجمع وكذلك ايضا في غرف المرضى
والطواقم الطبيه مما يؤدي الى حاله من
الهلع والخوف في داخل المجمع اضافه الى
انه يعيق عمل الطواقم الطبيه في هذا
المجمع المكتظ بالجرحى حيث ان هناك اكثر
من 350 جريح الان بحاجه ماسه للتدخلات
العلاجيه والجراحه لا تستطيع الطواقم
الطبيه الان مع الاستهداف المركز لمحيط
المستشفى ووصول شضايا ال نيران الاحتلال
القيام بواجبها وبالتالي نحن الان طواقمنا
الطبيه تعيش حاله من الضعر في اثناء
تقديمها للخدمات الصحيه لجرحى العدوان
الاسرائيل اضافه الى ان الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي من خلال الاستهداف يمنع خروج
الجرحى باتجاه المستشفى الميداني الاردني
الذي يبعد بضعه مترات عن مجمع الناصر
الطبي من اجل
ا العمليات الجراحيه حيث ان غرف العمليات
بمجمع طبي مقتض وملاه عن بكره ابيها ولا
تستطيع استقبال حالات جديده وبالتالي
ساضطر طواقم الطبيه الى تحويل الجرحى
باتجاه مستشفى الميداني الاردني القريب
والمجاور لمجمع الناصر الطبي ولكن كثافه
النيران تمنع الطواقم الطبيه من التحرك
بالجرحى باتجاه مستشفى الميداني الاردني
اضافه الى ان الطواقم الطبيه الان تتعامل
مع الحالات وهي تفترش الارض لانه لا يوجد
اي اسره ممكن ان تستقبل عليها الحالات
الجديده هناك حاله من الضر الشديد بين
الجرحه وبين الطواقم الطبيه في داخل مجمع
ناصر الطبي اضافه الى ان هناك عدم قدره
لسيارات الاسعاف للتحرك في المناطق
الغربيه لمدينه خانيونس لانتشال الضحايا
حيث ابلغنا من خلال المواطنين بان هناك
عشرات الشهداء ملقون على الارض وكذلك
عشرات الجرحى ايضا ملقون على الارض لا
تستطيع الوصول الى المستشفيات ولا تستطيع
الطواقم الطبيه وسيارات الاسعاف الوصول
اليها وبالتالي الاحتلال الاسرائيلي يعزل
مجمع ناصر الطبي ومستشفى الامل تماما عن
حركه سيارات اسعاف وعن وصول الجرحى
والمرضى اليه وبالتالي نحن نطالب الامم
المتحده ونطالب كافه المؤسسات الامميه
بضروره حمايه مجمع نصر الطبي ومستشفى
الامل وكذلك ايضا حمايه الطواقم الطبيه
وتسيير حركه سيارات الاسعاف من داخل
المستشفيات والرجوع اليها اضافه الى ان
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي خلال الساعات الماضيه
كما اشرنا انه تم اقتحام مستشفى الخير
للولاده في غرب مدينه خانيونس حيث اجبر
النساء اللواتي وضعن اولادهن من خلال
العمليات القيصريه بترك المستشفى بعد
اجراء العمليات الجراحيه مشيا على الاقدام
او من خلال الكراريس بعد ان قام باحداث
مجزره في هذه المستشفى من خلال القاء
القنابل المدفعيه باتجاه المستشفى مما ادى
الى استشهاد اكثر من 10 مواطنين وكذلك
اصابه العديد من المواطنين وال القاطنين
في داخل المستشفى والان تم اخلاء المستشفى
بشكل كامل واجبار النساء الذين وضعنا
اولادهن من خلال عمليات القيصريه او الذين
على وشك الولاده للتوجه باتجاه منطقه رفح
ظروف غير امنه وقاسيه وربما هذا يهدد
حياتهن بخطر الموت وبالتالي الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي يتعمد قتل المدنيين وقتل
ايضا السيدات الحوامل وكذلك ايضا قتل
الجرحى دون تقديم رعايه صحيه لهم شكرا
جزيلا لك الدكتور اشرف القدره المتحدث
باسم وزاره الصحه